et maintenant Tom villa
bonne année Thierry bonne année à tous
bonne année
[Applaudissements]
par contre Thierry si je peux me
permettre d'être trompé parce que le
nouvel an chinois c'est le 7 février
boun vous l'avez invité trop tôt en fait
c'est un copain on partage la même scène
toutes les semaines on joue dans la cave
d'un restaurant bon sauf que Boon il est
à la plonge mais
non non ton surnom c'est chinois marrant
c'est un peu raciste moi je cautionne
pas voilà c'est comme si on disait je
pars Rachida Dati c'est l'arabe
ambitieuse franchement ça se fait pas
non mais c'est vrai
mais un chinois marrant c'est génial
comme concept le problème c'est qu'un
chinois qui sourit on sait jamais si
c'est parce qu'il est content ou qui
parce qu'il prépare un sale
coupé
tu peux me payer moins cher que le
faire attention à ce qu'on dit parce que
le problème c'est que ce que je suis en
France c'est qu'un chinois qui fait des
blagues sur les Chinois c'est normal un
blanc qui fait des blagues sur les
Chinois c'est un raciste alors qu'un
chinois qui fait des blagues au blanc ça
s'appelle un restaurateur donc il faut
faire
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
Rachida tout va bien se passer parce que
je l'aime beaucoup vraiment Rachida
c'était la première à montrer qu'on
pouvait être une femme en politique et
avoir du style donc ça c'est bien juste
pour réagir à une petite polémique parce
que sur internet il y a des gens qui qui
ont dit que vous pensez que vous aviez
fait de la chirurgie esthétique moi je
pense pas que vous en avez besoin non
mais vraiment non mais c'est vrai
moi ça me fait marrer la chirurgie
esthétique parce que on veut on veut que
ça se voit mais on veut pas que ça se
sache un peu comme quand on voit de
Front national en fait c'est
alors
[Applaudissements]
Rachida vous êtes député européenne il y
a des avantages et des inconvénients on
le seul avantage que je vois c'est que
les députés français tous les mercredis
ils ont leur émission sur France 3 donc
ça veut dire que on voit ceux qui
bossent ou ceux qui se vend les couilles
alors qu'à Strasbourg personne ne sait
ce qui se passe c'est vrai non mais
c'est vrai j'ai vu un reportage à la
télé il y a des députés ils sont
tellement vicieux ils vont pointer à 7h
du matin et après il se barre et il saut
dans le premier TGV moi je trouve ça
dégueulasse mais pour 10000 euros par
mois moi aussi je fais des
allers-retours à Strasbourg franchement
vous ne pouvez pas signer partir parce
que sinon vous n'êtes pas payé vous avez
un quota d'or à respecter première chose
et on gagne pas 10000 euros par mois et
tout est sur Internet
Stéphane Plaza voilà vous êtes animateur
télé comédien agent immobilier alors
j'ai appris que vous aviez vécu jusqu'à
l'âge de 30 ans avec votre maman l'agent
immobilier qui vit chez ses parents
jusqu'à l'âge de 30 ans j'avais bien
dire quand même les coordonnées sont les
plus mal chaussées chez les Juifs c'est
farades c'est tôt mais sinon c'est tard
pourtant encore mesdames et messieurs je
suis ici pour vous poser les questions
trop con que Thierry Ardisson n'a pas
voulu vous poser
Rachida Dati alors dans la politique on
dit que vous n'aimez pas vous faire
marcher sur les pieds c'est à cause de
vos chaussures de luxe ou pas
on dit Rachida que pour ne rien rater de
ce qui se passe dans les halls du 7e
arrondissement chaque mois vous recevez
les concierges à la mairie du 7e du coup
vous avez mis longtemps à prendre le
portugais ou pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes chinois vous faites des
blagues c'est parce que vous étiez trop
nul en chant pour le karaoké
Stéphane Plaza
félicitations Stéphane j'ai lu que vous
aviez trouvé votre moitié vous pouvez
nous la décrire fait combien de mètres
carrés loi Carrez
apparente ou pas non il y a pas de
c'est si on va dans le Marais je ne vais
pas dans le Marais
petit débrief de la semaine dernière
Thierry bah sur Internet les twittos ont
été très virulents avec vous parce que
vous avez beaucoup critiqué François
Hollande et franchement je vous soutiens
pas non non mais c'est vrai non mais ça
se fait pas il nous a prouvé quand même
qu'il était capable
qui était capable qui était capable de
bien porter les fleurs qui jouaient très
bien la tristesse voilà si jamais en
2017 François Hollande y est parait élu
bon on sait qui il pourra bosser chez
Interflora ou cheroke éclair tout
simplement
on va pas faire les mythos hein tu l'as
fait pendant 2 ans au Grand Journal qui
sait mieux que personne ce que je suis
en train de vivre ça je peux te le dire
venir faire des vannes aux invités qui
qui font la gueule souvent
on l'a vu la semaine dernière
c'était pas évident de savoir quand elle
était content ou quoi elle faisait la
gueule ça a commencé bon par le Jamel
Comedy Club avec Fabrice Éboué c'est
quand même vous qui vous en êtes le
mieux sorti sincèrement tu crois que
Claudia Tagbo ça l'a fait un arrêt de
faire le décor penché
c'est normal
en tout cas toi Angel aujourd'hui on
sent que c'est un homme plus mûr plus
posé c'est vrai alors je sais pas si
c'est le fait d'être papa ou d'être
blindé mais on sent que il est bien dans
sa tête non mais c'est vrai et Thomas
c'est aussi le cinéma case départ le
crocodile du botswanga FastLife non
dedans il joue un esclave un dictateur
africain un champion d'athlétisme bravo
les clichés que des rôles de noir et le
pire c'est que c'est lui qui écrit ses
films donc tout simplement voilà le
prochain si tu joues un éboueur je te
jure je t'envoie SOS Racisme au cul tout
simplement
Michel Bernier Michel vous avez fait vos
premiers packs Mimie Mathy et Isabelle
lebeauton dans le petit théâtre de
Bouvard alors pour les plus jeunes qui
nous regardent le petit de Bouvard
c'était un peu l'ancêtre du Jamel Comedy
Club voilà donc tu sais ce que ça veut
dire Thomas va peut-être que dans 20 ans
toi aussi tu joueras un ange qui claque
des doigts sur TF1 mais non mais c'est
au petit c'est au petit théâtre de
pouvoir que vous avez rencontré la
gloire et puis aussi le papa de vos
enfants Bruno Gaccio c'est vrai que
c'est souvent sur le lieu de travail
qu'on rencontre l'amour c'est mais
regardez pas comme ça mais regardez pas
comme ça non non en plus je déteste les
Mon Chéri que vous m'avez livré
franchement
Jacques Attali ah voilà le plus
déconneur des trois ce soir Jacques tu
lui laisses la parole 5 minutes il te
sort connerie sur connerie non mais
c'est vrai Patrick Sébastien à côté
c'est un petit chanteur à la croix de
bois Polytechnique école des mines
Sciences Po Lena tout ça pour finir la
plupart du temps sur BFM TV c'est quoi
Jacques alors c'est la Jacques à chaque
fois que vous êtes invité sur un plateau
on vous demande de faire des prédictions
tu vas économie ce que vous auriez dû
faire c'est voyante Jacques tu lui files
je sais pas un voile des boucles
d'oreilles un jeu de tarot une caravane
au bois de Boulogne et puis voilà vous
aurez gagné plus d'argent
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser Michel Bernier alors plus jeunes
vous avez démarré je l'ai dit avec Mimie
Mathy ça vous fait quoi que aujourd'hui
ça soit elle qui vous regarde de haut
Thierry franchement c'est ça dégueulasse
votre compagne Carole rocher c'est aussi
votre metteur en scène est-ce que du
coup vous avez fait à faire la
différence quand vous couchez pour le
plaisir ou quand vous couchez pour le
boulot comme dit Michel dans son livre
couché pour réussir du moment qu'on
réussit
[Rires]
et pour terminer vous avez un frère
jumeau Bernard Bernard Tapie mais
contrairement aux frères Bogdanov vous
avez décidé de ne pas faire carrière
avec lui il est si moche que ça
la semaine dernière on a reçu Jacques
Attali voilà qui compte peut-être se
présenter à la présidentielle de 2017
alors beaucoup de gens sur Twitter ont
été très enthousiasmés par les
propositions qu'il a faites certains
sont même prêts à voter pour lui
paraît-il j'ada liste comme Martina
Christian Dupont Attali ou Jérôme Attali
ça part très très bien cette affaire
très beau plateau ce soir Thierry Lorie
Lorie l'idole des jeunes du début des
années 2000 on vous a vu nette sur
Internet comme Justin Bieber ou René la
Taupe
alors le riz attention on rigole pas
c'est 4 tournées 2 millions de
spectateurs ça veut dire ça fait près de
un français sur 25 alors si tu enlèves
les bébés les prisonniers les vieux et
les pédophiles qu'on a pas le droit
d'approcher les enfants ça fait un
Français sur trois c'est énorme
c'est vrai Lorie maintenant faut vous
appeler Lorie pester
autant pour moi rassure c'est pas pour
changer l'image c'est juste pour [__]
les impôts
voilà les [__] c'est une très belle
association qui donne pas des repas ceux
qui peuvent pas manger et puis un micro
à ceux qui peuvent pas chanter
non mais là vous faites votre retour au
théâtre pour la pièce Pygmalion
d'ailleurs il y a votre collaboratrice
Caroline qui a dit de vous à vous
surnomme le phénix je crois voilà c'est
vrai alors c'est pas méchant mais je
crois que ça colle beaucoup plus à
Jean-Pierre Chevènement quand même c'est
non mais ça va être Jean-Pierre
Chevènement c'est après Denver le
dernier dinosaure Jean-Pierre le dernier
des éléphants du PS parce que j'ai
demandé à Thierry pourquoi on vous
recevait il m'a expliqué que c'était
pour prouver à votre case de retraite
que vous étiez toujours parmi nous non
alors Jean-Pierre on est obligé d'en
parler parce que bah la fin est heureuse
c'est chouette voilà vous avez fait un
coma de 8 jours en 98 vous rendez compte
il a vu la lumière blanche au bout du
tunnel ou alors c'était juste le médecin
avec sa lampe pour vérifier mais non
mais c'était peut-être la morphine c'est
vrai non mais Jean-Pierre c'est le seul
qui peut nous dire quand même c'est quoi
le plus dur vivre après un coma ou vivre
après un mandat de François Hollande
c'est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
Issa Doumbia
Issa comédien humoriste ou jouer dans la
série nos chers voisins sur TF1
en breton de 23 ans tout à fait je sais
pas ce qui était le plus dur de faire
croire que vous étiez étudiant ou breton
mais
non Marie Le Pen a vu ça il en a fait
tomber son œil de verre mais mesdames
messieurs je suis ici pour vous poser
les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous poser Lorie
à l'âge de 5 ans où il y a de Michael
Jackson c'est à dire Willi être noir et
battue par votre père c'est ça Doumbia
Issa dans TPMP vous avez déclaré enlever
Julien Lepers à question pour un
champion c'est comme enlever Mickey à
Disney
c'est la place de Nabilla que vous avez
pris dans TPMP
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Pierre Chevènement tourné faire
garagiste
dernière question Jean-Pierre
Chevènement est-ce que pendant que vous
étiez dans le dans le coma vous souvenez
avoir été sollicité par gentil Berry
pour voter dans le 5e arrondissement ou
pas c'était bien possible merci voilà
c'était Tom villa Thierry la semaine
dernière petit débrie pour sauver
Jean-Pierre Chevènement qui était très
très sympa les gens ont adoré sur
Internet et ils ont beaucoup aimé
l'interview vous président voilà et
c'est marrant parce que j'ai regardé
c'est à vous la semaine dernière et ils
ont fait Amanda Lear une interview
Amanda Lear présidente
comme ça calmez-vous les lèche-culs
non non mais ça doit être le hasard
voilà moi je dis vous allez faire c'est
à vous la semaine prochaine ou pas c'est
déjà fait vous savez quoi si jamais vous
le refaites hop vous en avez besoin
non mais vous savez quoi parce que à la
limite on leur envoie directement
comme ça c'est bon mais non mais parce
que les mecs ils se font chier à
regarder notre émission du coup là comme
ça ils lisent directement les fiches
si vous repassez dans le coin
[Applaudissements]
c'est la classe c'est vrai c'est son
dernier film chocolat qui raconte la vie
du premier clown noir voilà alors il
paraît que Joe Wilfried Tsonga a passé
le casting mais il était déjà tellement
mauvais donc Kinder Bueno du coup ça l'a
pas fait
je dis vous soutenez le boycot de la
cérémonie des Oscars par des artistes
noirs américains voilà c'est très bien
rushi mais là il gueule parce que il y a
pas de noir aux Oscars nous personne ne
gueule parce qu'il y a pas de noir tout
court non mais c'est vrai aux États-Unis
ils ont Will Smith Samuel Jackson Denzel
Washington Morgan Freeman Jamie Fox
Chris Rock nous on a qui Omar Sy et
Michel Leeb c'est pauvre non mais c'est
vrai
[Applaudissements]
Marc trevidique bonjour bonjour Marc
ancien juge antiterroriste alors je vous
fais une petite confidence à la base
Thierry voulait vous accueillir sur la
chanson la bombe humaine de téléphone
mais après il s'est dit que c'était
encore un peu tôt non mais ça c'est
comme accueillir Oscar Pistorius sur
ever lève-toi ou
Omar si sur chaud cacao c'est pas de
très bon goûts voilà alors Marc vous
avez passé 10 ans avoir les terroristes
vous les avez vu début débuter vous les
avez reçus écouter pendant des heures en
fait
Marc reedict c'est le Michel Drucker des
terroristes
sauf que pour Michel 6 heures sur un
canapé avec un chien posé des questions
c'est une émission lui c'est une garde à
vue mais sinon c'est vrai ce que tu
arrives
Nicole Ferroni Nicole alors pour tous
ceux qui l'ignorent vous avez été
découverte par Laurent Ruquier voilà
donc au moins on sait que vous avez pas
couché pour réussir mais non mais avant
d'être humoriste vous avez été
professeur de SVT alors là vous êtes sur
scène avec votre spectacle l’œuf la
poule ou Nicole voilà jouer pour la
première fois en 2010 2010 2016 si
j'avais été prof j'aurais dit 100 Doors
sur ses acquis
mais ce que j'aime bien chez vous c'est
qu'un côté artisanal c'est vrai pour
trouver les salles en tournée où vous
produire vous utilisez les propositions
des fans je crois c'est ça voilà alors
du coup je donne les dates de tournée
Nicole Ferroni le 6 février a Connerré
le 12 mars à Argenton-sur-Creuse le 8
avril la glenet et le 23 avril à
Basse-Goulaine voilà en fait c'est pas
une tournée c'est un calendrier de repas
de famille mais sinon
vous me direz tant que les gens payent
mesdames messieurs je suis ici pour vous
poser les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous poser Marc
prévu vous êtes né dans un papa breton
et d'une maman basque ça veut dire que
pendant les grandes vacances scolaires
vous aviez un mois de merde sur deux
[Rires]
moi je disais vous avez dit j'ai le cœur
qui bat pour la paix c'est vraiment de
vous vous l'avez piqué une candidat de
Miss France
[Rires]
et pour terminer rushi vous êtes
d'origine marocaine alors plus jeune
vous avez trafiqué votre CV pour pour
passer un casting vous avez d'autres
points communs Rachida Dati
petit débrief des missions de la semaine
dernière sur les réseaux sociaux les
gens trouvent que vous avez encore fait
du Hollande bashing aïe Thierry je vous
avais dit j'y arrive pas on va écouter
je vous ai fait une fiche pour essayer
de dire du bien de François Hollande on
va essayer on va faire un truc
il est gentil et il mange bien la
cantine non non c'est le neveu
il est gentil
[Applaudissements]
quel plateau ce soir Thierry Daniel
Auteuil Daniel Eno donc plus grands
acteurs en France alors au début vous
avez joué un ado qui passait le bac dans
les sous-doués alors vous aviez 29 ans
et tout le monde y a cru voilà bon en
même temps comme j'ai lu que vous aviez
redoublé trois fois votre quatrième en
fait le bac à 29 ans c'était pas un film
c'était un documentaire
alors on est obligé d'en parler voilà on
vous avait proposé Bienvenue chez les
Ch'tis intouchables et finalement ça
c'est pas fait de film 40 millions de
spectateurs c'est pas grave voilà c'est
pas l'eau mais c'est pas grave il
pouvait pas les faire
tout le temps ça dans le cinéma regarder
Coluche et Jacques Villeret dû jouer
Hugolin et finalement ça c'est pas cher
une bonne chose Mickey qui avait refusé
le flic de Beverly Hills Richard Gere
Piège de Cristal passe partout Game of
Thrones donc ça arrive tout le temps ça
c'est non mais c'est vrai Daniel Auteuil
en ce moment vous mettez en scène et
vous jouez dans la pièce l'envers du
décor où les les pensées secrètes des
personnages doubles les vrais dialogues
et ça je trouve c'est une excellente
idée voilà je vous le disais même si
c'est de la merde je vais pas lui dire
maintenant je vraiment j'ai adoré la
pièce
et puis je trouve que c'est très bien vu
voilà votre duo avec Valérie Bonneton
fonctionne à merveille
[Applaudissements]
Younes c'est Bambi l'arabe et le Juif
alors juste avant de commencer dites-moi
qui est le Juif qui est le polygame qui
est le lui c'est moi c'est le
coproducteur alors avant le spectacle
s'appelait l'arabe et le juif et vous
avez retiré le titre de la fiche moi
j'ai un nouveau titre à vous proposer mi
cacher mial mais 100% circoncis ça ça
peut être c'est très bien ça
[Musique]
Pascal Delatour du pain ah le meilleur
pour la fin la star de BFM TV
le matin c'est William Leymergie et les
Lapins Crétins alors
janvier 2015 BFM TV basse record
d'audience à cause des attentats voilà
BFM TV la chaîne qui va bien quand la
France va mal alors mais moi ce que
j'aime beaucoup sur BFM TV c'est les
témoignages parce que quand il y a un
drame on chope toujours celui qui est le
plus près de la situation le voisin et
le voisin il a toujours la même phrase
écoutez je suis extrêmement surpris
vraiment je m'y attendais pas du tout
alors pour nous c'était quelqu'un de
sympathie qu'il allait chercher les
gamins à l'école il nous disait bonjour
le matin non mais c'est vrai en 10 ans
de BFM TV on n'a jamais vu un mec dire
ah ouais [__] enfin ça fait trois ans
qu'il égorge des chats dans sa cave et
il y avait beaucoup il y a que vous qui
l'aviez pas vu non mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
pour vous poser les questions trop con
que Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
parce qu'elle le Latour du pain alors
vous êtes la seconde matinale de télé de
France juste derrière Télématin c'est
comment d'être derrière William
Leymergie rider non
[Rires]
comment tu vas te sortir de ça
Daniel Auteuil alors Daniel pour votre
dernier mariage vous aviez choisi dev
comme témoin voilà c'est pour l'empêcher
de chanter à la cérémonie
[Applaudissements]
les Chevaliers du Fiel les chevaliers
c'est très impressionnant parce que il y
a encore 10 ans tout le monde se foutait
d'eux et aujourd'hui il remplissent des
Zéniths ils font des prime sur des 8 à 2
millions de téléspectateurs c'est génial
ça fait 25 ans qu'ils font marrer les
Français comme les Balkany sauf que eux
ils le font exprès mais non mais nous on
déclare ce qu'on gagne
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai on se méfie pas
parce que ils ont des têtes à bosser à
la DDE alors que c'est quand même les
fonctionnaires qui bossent le plus en
France c'est vrai alors votre dernier
spectacle s'appelle
Otake voilà je montre au taquet au
taquet comme ça voilà non c'est toujours
un coup d'avance parce qu'ils avaient
déjà anticipé la réforme de
l'orthographe bravo les gars
sans l'action circonflexe Xavier
Demoulin c'est vrai Xavier alors Xavier
vous avez failli être dans le Bronx
voilà vous êtes resté trois mois chez
les franciscains du Bronx voilà alors
qu'est-ce qu'un prêtre Francis quin dans
le Bronx le matin il prit et
l'après-midi il dit le la drogue voilà
c'est un cliché il y a des fois où il
prie pas
arnane cors voilà Thierry franchement
vous pensez qu'on l'a pas reconnu Cyril
Hanouna
je vous rassure vous inquiétez pas on
peut faire des blagues à Rennes voilà vu
qu'elle est anglaise j'ai donné un
mauvais texte à traductrice donc tout se
passe bien alors arnane Corse vous êtes
la femme à barbe voilà vous savez qu'en
France ça nous impressionne pas du tout
parce que nous on a déjà la femme à
couilles c'est Marine Le Pen donc
franchement c'est
[Applaudissements]
où est-ce qu'il me dérange je sais pas
quel est une barbe c'est son pote là
avec les nichons dans les loges là par
contre je trouve ça limite
[Rires]
Saint-André alors l'ancienne entraîneur
du 15 de France de rugby votre surnom
c'est le goret PSA ou encore ou un ou un
[Rires]
je vais rester sur Philippe Saint-André
parce que vous êtes trop près de moi on
sait jamais ça peut partir alors Thierry
je vous ai préparé un petit lexique du
rugby parce que je sais que c'est pas
votre domaine de prédilection
je ne cautionne pas du tout mais en même
temps c'est lui qui me paye c'était très
drôle Thierry mais alors voilà des
petits termes techniques du rugby par
exemple tampon alors tampon plaquage
très violent alors point commun du
tampon entre les femmes et l'importation
du rugby lié au moment où les Anglais
ont débarqué
alors 8 hommes qui s'emboîtent afin de
conquérir le ballon voilà alors ça c'est
sur une pelouse parce que dans le Marais
ça s'appelle un bar bien entendu
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Xavier Demoulin alors Xavier de moulin
votre surnom c'est le sanglier on est
d'accord que vous n'avez pas la même
alimentation que le sanglier ça dépend
des jours ça dépend des jours très très
faim je suis capable de manger de tout
d'accord ça m'arrive
comment ça se passe dans les hammam faut
que vous attendiez les jours mixtes du
coup ou pas
tout la troisième mi-temps du match
après les All Blacks chez le psy
à Cardiff les chevaliers alors la
question tout le monde se pose enfin
surtout Thierry qui dans votre duo écrit
les sketchs et qui fait la femme
et il fait la femme aussi dans les
pièges très beau ce soir
keV
adamsé faire des vannes aux invités keV
il remplit des élites au cinéma un bide
pour lui c'est un million d'entrée
franchement il y a que capillairement
parlant ou là c'est il est prenable mais
c'est vrai il a fait son Vivement
Dimanche c'est plus jeune à voir eu son
émission c'est vrai en même temps
c'était pas compliqué le plus jeune
avant keV c'était Gérard Lenorman mais
enfin quand même
alors tiens votre votre nouveau film
s'appelle ami public voilà c'est
l'histoire d'un garçon qui organise un
faux braquage avec ses potes pour
réaliser le rêve de son frère malade
voilà en gros c'est un peu un mélange de
d'oce eleven's et du Téléthon mais sans
George Clooney et sans Sophie Davant en
tout cas très malin le dernier film
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a des
mauvaises critiques des gens un peu
malveillants on peut dire [__] vous
êtes pas sympa les gars ça parle du
cancer quand même comme ça tout le monde
culpabilise mais ça marche très bien non
mais c'est vrai d'ailleurs ils auraient
pu le faire pour les Bronzés 3 ils
auraient pu faire sur l'euthanasie comme
ça ça va éviter qu'il se fasse défoncer
c'est quand même ballon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça attaque vénère vénère
[Rires]
Franck le même début de carrière que
Michel Bernier il a commencé dans un
trio il y avait un nain et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous venez pour votre deuxième
film voilà Pattaya qu'elle a la vraie
fosse sud des caillera en Thaïlande la
Thaïlande qui a eu connaissait ces
paysages ces îles sa gastronomiste et
massage avec ou sans finition et alors
dans le film Pattaya vous jouez de votre
ressemblance avec Vin Diesel c'est
ravine diesel c'est votre sosie
américain c'est la classe bon en France
c'est Philippe Etchebest c'est un peu
plus pourri
[Applaudissements]
Lambert Wilson alors là attention grand
monsieur c'est une classe la tournée
avec les plus grands réalisateurs et
aussi avec Fabien antoniete
ce qui est bien avec Lambert c'est que
c'est un petit peu la boule à facette un
coup comédien un coup chanteur là il
revient avec un album de reprise de Yves
Montand très très bon choix voilà c'est
vrai que les jeunes connaissent pas
forcément mais en même temps dans les
albums hommage il restait plus grand
monde tu vois entre Goldman Balavoine
Bashung Barbara Ferré bon là il restait
Yves Montand et Annie Cordy donc
forcément c'est le prochain
alors Thérèse vous êtes belle blonde et
vous parlez de sexe voilà comme Clara
Morgane bon sauf que vous c'est le
cerveau qui est bien rempli mais
vous êtes sexologue et vous passez dans
tous les collèges et les lycées de
France c'est sûr que les questions elles
ont dû évoluer tu vois aujourd'hui elle
est à l'époque on se demandait comment
on faisait les bébés aujourd'hui c'est
pour ou contre la bifle donc c'est sûr
que ça doit être un petit peu non
vous le dites voilà les ados ont
l'angoisse de la performance sexuelle
voilà et c'est vrai que qui a 20 ans on
se demande combien de temps on va tenir
alors qu'à à 60 on se demande combien de
temps on va attendre avant que ça vienne
[Applaudissements]
le vrai le vrai Grégory c'est qu'il a
regardé Thierry sur cette vague
je suis le souffre-douleur de mon stage
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu
Kev Adams que vous avez passé le casting
à l'époque du film LOL voilà mais la
directrice de casting vous avez recalé
parce qu'elle pensait que vous feriez
Paris les jeunes vous avez des nouvelles
depuis qu'il y a boss pour Plus Belle La
Vie maintenant
des bisous à toi
Lambert vous chantez Yves Montand
exactement comme dit ça c'est très
impressionnant c'est quoi l'intérêt
d'acheter votre album plutôt que solide
mon temps à part non à part le fait que
vous pouvez faire des concerts et des
dédicaces
c'est ça
je suis présent fond Gastambide Franck
sur le tournage de des Daltons à
l'époque vous occupiez du dressage de
rente en plan je crois c'est ça qui
s'occupait de dresser Ramzy alors
et pour finir theres argot vous êtes
sexologue dans une école catholique
privée d'ailleurs du coup c'est vous qui
gérez quand un enfant de cœur plaque un
prêtre
alors beau plateau Thierry ce soir mais
ce soir c'est pas évident parce que
voilà je vous le dis voilà job c'est un
copain donc je vais pas défoncer un
copain André Bercoff voilà
on est la fleuriste c'est une fille je
veux pas défoncer une fille voilà donc
Pascal Obispo bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
un peu de box
chanteur chauve marié un mannequin s'il
avait été noir on aurait eu s'il dommage
on a Pascal Obispo
Pascal Obispo faut pas l'oublier c'est
les tubes c'est aussi un showman et
d'ailleurs Pascal vous avez déclaré je
me sens
inutile si je ne pars pas en tournée
alors je vous rassure parce que votre
tourneur il pense exactement la même
chose
alors votre dernière album s'appelle
billet de femme voilà il a été fait à
partir des poèmes de Marceline Desbordes
Valmore datant 1819 alors Pascal vous
avez dit que c'était en retrouvant un
vieux carnet de votre papa vous avez
découvert cette poétesse moi je suis sûr
que la vraie histoire c'est Line Renaud
aussi d'action qui lui a donné les
poèmes de sa vieille copine de scène
[Applaudissements]
Jeff panacloc Jeff le garçon qui a
dépoussiéré la ventriloquille voilà
alors le principe de la ventriloquille
je le rappelle c'est de parler sans
bouger les lèvres comme Didier Deschamps
et
non Jeff il sait ce que je viens en ce
moment parce que faire des vannes aux
invités il a fait pendant trois ans au
plus grand cabaret du monde sans
déconner va faire des blagues ou entre
deux jongleurs bulgares et trois
danseuses portoricaines
en tout cas mine de rien Jeff et
Jean-Marc c'est le seul duo qui n'a
aucune chance de se séparer c'est vrai
si un jour ils sont plus ensemble c'est
juste parce que Jeff a oublié sa valise
avec Jean-Marc dedans l'aéroport
en plus votre bureau il a peur de rien
la plus grande peur à la limite c'est
comme Amanda Lear c'est que Jean-Marc a
une couture qui lâche à la limite mais
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi mais parce qu'elle est jeune
elle est jolie elle est drôle il y a
forcément un truc qui cloche si tu as
tué ta sœur jumelle quand tu étais petit
tu peux nous le dire
alors vous jouez votre spectacle au
Point Virgule spectacle des conseillers
au moins de 16 ans c'est con c'est con
non mais si parce que ça coupe une
partie du public quoi les pédophiles
aussi ils ont droit de se marrer
André Bercoff alors actuellement vous
êtes journaliste à Valeurs Actuelles
alors journal un petit peu de droite on
peut le dire voilà il vient à droite
c'est entre minutes et Picsou Magazine
voilà alors c'est vous qui avez obtenu
la seule interview française de Donald
Trump européenne même [__] la classe
alors Donald Trump pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est les idées de Le
Pen mais dans le corps de François
Valéry voilà à peu près
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
tout ça pour ça exactement Pascal Obispo
Pascal votre votre fils s'appelle Sean
sa sœur s'appelle seven le prochain il
va s'appeler comment Ocean's Eleven ou
bien
on est là fleurie on est là vous êtes en
couple avec l'humoriste Mustapha El
Atrassi qui a produit et co-écrit votre
spectacle comment ça se passe quand vous
disputez il vous met une salle critique
sur Billetreduc
ça arrive ouais André Bercoff André vous
qui avez passé plus d'une heure avec
Donald Trump qu'est-ce qui a été le plus
dur à supporter c'est propos racistes ou
ça coupe de cheveux
ni l'un ni l'autre et pour terminer Jeff
panacloc on vous a vu dans l'émission La
Parenthèse inattendue d'ailleurs vous
avez versé une petite larme c'est si dur
que ça de rester un weekend entier chez
Lopez
[Rires]
bon Thierry petit débrie de la semaine
dernière sur Twitter beaucoup de
réactions sur votre interview de Pascal
Obispo comme Spartacus Network qui nous
dit Ardisson passe son temps à glorifier
les mecs de 50 ou 60 ans en couple avec
des nanas de 30 ans de moins pas
terrible et je suis bien d'accord je
trouve ça non mais je trouve ça
dégueulasse les mecs de 60 piges qui se
tapent des nanas 30 ans moi ça me
scandalise
après ça dépend qui franchement non mais
c'est vrai non mais par contre un mec de
30 ans avec une fille de 60 ça n'a pas
d'intérêt ça s'appelle une brocante et
c'est dégueulasse
alors Olivier Besancenot bonsoir bonsoir
Olivier Besancenot c'est le c'est le
thon rouge de la politique en 2009 il
faisait 10% dans les sondages
aujourd'hui il est 1% si on fait rien il
va disparaître alors comme disait Gérard
rolls sauter les tons mobiliser vous non
mais c'est vrai selon un sondage BVA
cette semaine les Français se disent
favorables à une primaire commune à
l'ensemble des parties de gauche et ils
aimeraient voir en priorité Manuel Valls
47% Macron 46% et en queue de Ploton
François Hollande 29 et Olivier
Besancenot 28%. vous pouvez pas être
derrière François Hollande plus personne
ne l'a même mon chat quand il le voit à
la télé il se met en boule non moi j'ai
envie que vous sortir de là franchement
Olivier j'en ai marre que vous traîniez
dans la rue Olivier il fait tellement de
manif dans sa vie que quand ils sont à
une odeur de merguez ça lui rappelle
plus le boulot que les vacances
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je vais être très honnête avec
vous j'ai pas grandi avec vous parce que
je suis un peu mais non mais non mais
c'est vrai je suis un peu plus jeune moi
les stars du hip-hop quand j'étais jeune
c'était Willy Denza et Billy Crawford
c'était hip-hop non mais en plus moi
c'est vrai que ça me parle pas trop
chanson qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour
[__] le feu moi j'ai grandi en
Seine-et-Marne je veux dire si on
foutait le feu ça partait en feu de
forêt direct non mais honnêtement on
avait plus d'emmerdes avec les sangliers
qu'avec les flics
à 38 ans vous aviez dit que vous
n'alliez pas rappeler jusqu'à 50 ans
c'est loupé et aujourd'hui 50 ans vous
rappelez encore donc vous êtes la preuve
que quand on est jeune on dit beaucoup
de conneries
non mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
vous jouez dans le film éperdument qui
raconte l'histoire d'amour entre un
directeur de prison et une détenue je
sais le début ça fait début de film
porno enfin pas du tout dedans il y a
Guillaume Gallienne et un film porno
avec Guillaume Gallienne moi je regarde
pas
non mais ce qui est incroyable
d'ailleurs c'est que vous avez été
classé parmi les personnalités
européennes de moins de 30 ans les plus
influentes par le magazine Forbes voilà
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire être
influent je sais pas mais c'est bien
c'est bien d'ailleurs on va voir si vous
êtes vraiment influente ce que je
cherche un appart donc ça c'est mon
dossier
je suis stagiaire j'ai pas de garant
j'ai trois chiens deux chats et joue de
la batterie vas-y démerde-toi
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
vous avez dit je ne reviens pas pour
l'argent j'ai le poker pour ça et Joey
Starr qui fait la Nouvelle Star vous
voulez pas lui apprendre le poker plutôt
Adèle Adèle Exarchopoulos vous allez
dire à propos de votre carrière j'avais
envie qu'on me laisse faire des erreurs
voilà pensez à quoi en disant ça à vos
débuts dans RS police scientifique
Olivier Besançon vous êtes toujours
postier et vous êtes ancien chef de fil
de l'extrême gauche alors du coup vous
êtes ici sur votre temps de congé ou
votre temps de grève
[Applaudissements]
tu es le Chameroy de cette émission
ça veut dire que je prenne du recul
c'est ça non
bonsoir à tous et Louis Plenel et lui
c'est le moustachu le plus célèbre des
journalistes politiques avec l'autre qui
bosse sur LCI Arlette Chabot et
non mais alors Edwig j'ai appris que
vous aviez passé votre jeunesse en
Algérie ce qui explique cette moustache
de chanteurs de raï Cheb Plenel non mais
Edwige il y a pas que la moustache moi
ce que j'aime beaucoup chez lui c'est
votre petit regard malicieux et le
problème c'est que du coup quand il
sourit on sait jamais si c'est parce
qu'il est content ou parce qu'il a un
dossier sur toi
c'est le fondateur de Mediapart alors
Mediapart c'est le journal qui sort des
dossiers sur tout le monde l'affaire est
en cours c'est eux la faire Cahuzac bon
Hanouna c'est pas eux mais ça aurait pu
ça aurait pu c'est vrai d'ailleurs vu
que c'est la grande mode de faire des
des dossiers sur les coulisses des
émissions faites un truc sur Salut les
Terriens
en vrai il est super sympa dans sa loge
il y a énormément de peluches on se
croirait au Disney Store les gréements
de fortune Thierry il aura retiré leur
passeport c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
bloqués là
on se voit après on se voit après
[Applaudissements]
Christophe Dugarry Christophe je l'adore
c'est quand même la preuve vivante qu'un
joueur moyen peut devenir un excellent
consultant mais non
[Applaudissements]
nous on
A de la France Télé ils ont Xavier
Gravelaine joueur moyen et consultant
pourri donc c'est quand même c'est vrai
98 Thierry j'avais 9 ans et je sais pas
si moi je collectionnais les points sur
les pots de Nutella et du coup j'avais
la médaille de Zidane j'avais les le sac
à dos Didier Deschamps et j'avais les
crampons en bois de Christophe et
non mais attends moi Christophe
sincèrement je l'aime beaucoup et puis
c'est une autre génération tout le monde
dit aujourd'hui le joueur de foot il
parle mal français mais bon à la limite
c'est pas grave on leur demande juste de
jouer moi le seul truc qui m'inquiète
c'est que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
seront dans 20 ans les consultants de
demain la gueule des analyses de match
ça va être sous-titré les jeunes dans
sport études il y a étude aussi il faut
pas l'oublier
[Applaudissements]
Joyce Jonathan c'est la classe on dirait
qu'elle sort d'un dessin animé Joyce non
mais c'est vrai la petite sœur de
Blanche-Neige et de Cendrillon tiens moi
je vous imagine le matin c'est des
oiseaux qui vous lave le dos il y a des
souris qui vous habitent
alors vous parlez le mandarin Joyce ça
c'est la classe gros marché le marché
asiatique pour les Français c'est
impressionnant puisqu'il y a de bien
c'est que par les mandarins c'est
pratique parce qu'on reste au chinois tu
peux donner les vrais noms des plats et
pas seulement les numéros
c'est vrai que c'est pratique
bon joyeus on est obligé d'en parler
vous aviez chanté pour la victoire de
François Hollande en 2012 et vous
remarquerez qu'en chantent pour la
gauche même si elle est nulle et bah
c'est quand même moins d'emmerde que
quand on chante pour la droite on fait
un gros bisou à Faudel et Enrico Macias
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Joyce on vous a vu dans Plus Belle La
Vie vous avez joué votre propre rôle
c'est vrai qu'ils vous ont fait quand
même passer un casting pour jouer votre
propre rôle c'est des conneries
Christophe moi j'ai une question vous
êtes toujours bronzé comment comment
vous faites parce qu'honnêtement c'est
pas en allant la voir des matchs à Metz
et à quand que vous avez ce temps-là
alors je te ferai remarquer que je ne
vais pas à Metz ni à quand faire les
matchs pour terminer Edwy Plenel vous
sortez un livre intitulé dire nous c'est
Franck Ribéry qui a trouvé le titre ou
pas
je vous avais pas dit Thierry je suis un
petit peu de de mentalisme de magie j'ai
fait une prédiction vous verrez à la fin
de l'acronique on va voir ce qui se
passe Dita Von tees bonsoir
brune à la peau claire aux lèvres
flamboyantes et à la poitrine généreuse
si elle était française c'était Roselyne
Bachelot mais on a de la chance
vous revenez au Crazy Horse jusqu'au 30
mars merci du fond du cœur parce que ça
nous évite le retour d'Arielle Dombasle
non mais c'est vrai
non
ok François vous l'avez toujours le
fauteuil que vous aviez dans intouchable
ou pas
mon avis c'est le meilleur moyen
je peux me permettre on peut faire un
petit selfie
ah oui
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
mais non mais c'est très gentil parce
que j'ai vu au crédit or s'il y a le
pack VIP à 2000 euros on peut voir le
spectacle après la rencontrer dans les
coulisses il faire une photo donc vous
m'avez économisé 2000 balles merci du
fond du cœur
la classe nos meilleurs acteurs vraiment
je suis fan de vous que j'ai pas de
vanne mais c'est sincère
de campagne un petit peu la suite de Dr
Quinn fan médecin mais sauf qu'à la fin
vous mariez pas et qu'un indien non mais
c'est fou ce thème de la désertification
médicale parce que en même temps c'est
vrai que après avoir vu la soupe aux
choux tu te dis pas spontanément tiens
tu viens de faire 10 ans d'études je
vais aller à la campagne soigner des
mecs qui passent leur temps à lâcher des
caisses et à se bourrer la gueule
Cyril elle est dans quand j'ai dit à ma
mère ce soir on reçoit Cyril Eldin m'a
dit qui ça et
non je lui dis maman Cyril Eldin le mec
il va faire chier les politiques à
l'Assemblée nationale elle m'a fait ah
oui alors Cyril vous êtes la bête noire
des hommes politiques vous les cherchez
vous les titiller vous êtes un peu le
petit frère relou de Jean-Michel Apathie
Thierry je vous ai dit quoi je fais de
la magie prédiction regardez bim
tu vas trop fort
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est très impressionnant c'est
cette tchatche ce bagou ce sens de
l'improvisation vous avez parce que
c'est ça qui est fou c'est que Cyril il
prépare rien il va et voilà on verra ce
qui se passe c'est un peu comme le
mandat de François Hollande c'est un peu
pareil c'est lui qui m'inspire alors
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Cyril Eldin quand les Balkany seront à
la retraite vous considérez vraiment
comme au chômage technique
je pourrais plus partir en vacances chez
eux donc
dites Avantis Dita sur scène vous prenez
votre bain dans une coupe de champagne
géante ça vous fait quoi d'avoir réalisé
le fantasme de Gérard Depardieu
François Cluzet François j'ai lu que
vous refusiez souvent de refaire une
seconde fois ce que vous aviez déjà vécu
dans votre métier ça va votre vie
sexuelle sinon ou pas bravo Thierry très
très beau plateau très très éclectique
ce soir Liane Foly Liane Foly bonsoir
bonsoir alors votre prénom c'est Eliane
falieix
j'ai pris deux paliers
vous avez choisi folie comme pseudo en
hommage à Salvador Dali je crois qu'il
clamait dans une pub qu'il était fou de
chocolat heureusement que vous avez pas
choisi la pub au vomaltine ah non mais
c'est vrai parce que sinon liane
dynamite ça fait plus drag queen que
artiste alors vous sortez un disque de
reprise qui s'appelle krouneuse voilà
d'ailleurs mais je crois que vous aimez
pas trop le terme de reprise vous
préférez relooking et je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ça c'est
vraiment on dit pas un ravalement de
façade mais un lifting et on lit pas une
sodomie mais un itinéraire
bonsoir bonsoir Eric de l'Académie
française s'il vous plaît ça peut
s'applaudir très très fort
[Applaudissements]
à rien
à l'Académie française contrairement à
la voiture tous les fauteuils sont à la
place du mort
mais non mais c'est vrai vu la moyenne
d'âge de l'Académie française
Eric vous avez 69 ans mais c'est un peu
le Justin Bieber voilà c'est ça
quand il sort il va draguer des gamines
de 75 ans et non mais d'ailleurs en fait
pour entrer à l'Académie française c'est
un peu comme avec Nagui avec son jeu
tout le monde veut prendre sa place bon
sauf que là à l'Académie l'élimination
est beaucoup plus définitive ça c'est
découvert que Orsenna c'était pas votre
vrai nom non plus [__] c'est la soirée
des pseudos ce soir c'est votre prénom
c'est Eric Arnou et vous tenez le nom
d'Orsenna de la vieille ville du rivage
des cirtes dans le roman de Julien GRAC
voilà donc tu vois alien il s'est un peu
plus casser le cul quand même mais
donc gynéco Doc Gynéco bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
je sais que il aime pas qu'on lui fasse
des vannes sur sur sa vie privée sur la
drogue ou sur Sarkozy malik Bentalha
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
alors malik Bentalha vous venez le voir
pour Pattaya Thierry juste une question
ce qui vient encore pour Pattaya vous
savez qu'on a reçu tous les comédiens de
bataille j'adore ce film non mais vous
avez des ronds dans le film ou quoi
la semaine prochaine c'est qui c'est le
mec du son c'est du samedi matin je me
suis tapé un ladyboy sans faire exprès
j'ai confondu les perches faut arrêter
de rire un peu quand même non mais Malik
je l'aime beaucoup parce qu'en plus on a
le même âge tu fais du stand-up je fais
du stand-up tu as bosse avec Morandini
je bosse avec Morandini tu fais du
cinéma je bosse avec morandini
[Rires]
on lui donne des vrais rôles de
composition genre Pattaya il joue une
caméra dans la vache il joue une caméra
dans New York il jouait une caméra qui
c'est qui ton agence et Rohff c'est
prochain film bonne nouvelle il va jouer
un épicier donc on évite les clichés ça
c'est la ça c'est très bien mesdames et
messieurs je suis ici pour vous poser
les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous poser
ah
Eric Orsenna ola Eric vous avez été la
plume de de François Mitterrand vous
savez que si vous aviez été la plume de
Frédéric Mitterrand vous auriez pas fini
au même endroit non
[Rires]
Foly liane vous avez dit je suis une
femme qui aime le miracle de la vie
c'est vous ou du Roi Lion
c'est un peu Walt Disney
et pour terminer dog vous dites parfois
dans la rue une voiture s'arrête et les
gens m'insultent en même temps vous
savez que si vous traversez la même
vitesse que vous parlez c'est normal
comment ça va Thierry tu vas bien
bonsoir bon on va faire un petit débrief
de l'émission de la semaine dernière sur
Twitter les gens trouvent que vous avez
trop forcé avec la promo de Pattaya le
film
ça fait trois fois je vous avais prévenu
ou pas Thierry non mais un moment faut
voilà faut y aller mollo il faut que
j'arrête là
elle a pas bougé il y a pas un truc
tu sais que normalement
c'était des cendres de Pascal Sevran
c'est Jean-Pierre Coffe alors
il faut être discrète
ça va se voir tout simplement voilà donc
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire très très
beau plateau ce soir Thierry voilà c'est
c'est un beau coup de diversité il y a
une Québécoise une Espagnole un
pied-noir c'est on est à l'ONU tout
simplement
Victoria Abril bonsoir bonsoir Victoria
c'est la grande star franco-espagnol
avec avec Julio Iglesias et la crise
financière et non alors c'est vrai que
vous venez pas nous voir souvent mais
c'est quand vous venez il y a de la
promo alors là on va tout faire la série
Clem sur TF1 il y a un film en Espagne
nassida paraguer et puis votre prix
victoire qui regroupe toute l'ensemble
de votre carrière donc si vous avez une
bagnole à vendre c'est maintenant
n'hésitez pas de
en tout ajouté rien vous cartonnez sur
TF1 que la série Clem et d'ailleurs j'ai
découvert vous mesurez un mètre 57 c'est
ça
cm presque et pas la même série que vous
jouiez sur TF1 vous auriez joué un ange
qui claque des doigts
je me méfie avec Victoria parce que je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez il y a
quelques années elle avait elle avait
giflé un journaliste qui avait mal parlé
de l'un de vos films qui n'avait pas vu
Harry habitant bonsoir
Harry je l'aime beaucoup et c'est très
sincère c'est un mec très très marrant
bon ce soir peut-être qu'il serait un
peu moins marrant que d'habitude parce
que le décor est pas penché mais
ary habitant les visiteurs 3 ils
s'emmerde plus il fait que des films qui
cartonnent et films à succès Harry en
deux films 20 millions de spectateurs 19
millions 8 et qu'est-ce qu'on a fait au
bon Dieu et 200000 avec Robin des bois
mais c'est là où on voit que c'est un
excellent comédien Harry parce que il
joue un marquis et voilà quand même
passé de coco
alors dans le film je crois Godefroy de
Montmirail vous appelle l'essuiku voilà
oui Thierry m'a donné le même surnom
mais pas pour les mêmes raisons en tout
cas
[Applaudissements]
Coeur de Pirate bonsoir Béatrice alors
Béatrice Martin Go revenez avec un
nouvel album et ça c'est très bien il y
a un an vous aviez fait partie du projet
la bande à Renaud il y avait toute la
jeune génération qui reprenait les tubes
de Renault en buvant du Rica ça c'était
vraiment bien et puis il y avait votre
prise de mistral gagnant qui m'avait
beaucoup touché mais ma chanson ma
préférée c'est votre tube c'est comme
des enfants c'est la chanson préférée
aussi du cardinal Barbarin
non votre nouvelle album s'appelle rose
et le single oublie-moi alors faut faire
très attention parce que Larusso avait
chanté tu m'oublieras et elle avait une
nez creux on l'a bien oublié
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas osé vous poser
Victoria Abril ah Victoria vous passez
votre temps entre la France et l'Espagne
est-ce que vous en profitez pour faire
des des gosses pour pas revenir à vide
c'est un truc au chocolat
est-ce que tu prends une gaufrette au
chocolat pour traverser le c'est un truc
spécial mais si il faut lui dire la
vérité
cœur de pirate pour terminer vous avez
repris Mistral gagnant de Renault good
Amy Winehouse d'où vient cette passion
pour les chanteurs alcooliques
bonsoir ça va petit petit débrief de
l'émission de la semaine dernière la
semaine dernière on a reçu Zineb la
journaliste de Charlie Hebdo voilà et
beaucoup de gens sur Twitter ont réagi
parce que Zineb a plusieurs fats je le
rappelle la fatwa c'est quand des gens
qui n'ont pas de couilles en veulent à
ceux qui en ont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Thierry très beau plateau ce soir là on
a la belle formule Ardisson une fille un
mec populaire et un mec intelligent et
le mec intelligent évidemment c'est
Denis Brogniart
oui merci mais non mais c'est vrai Denis
ça fait 15 ans qu'il a la meilleure
émission de télé au monde Koh-Lanta
Koh-Lanta c'est le seul boulot autant
lieu de travail et mieux que ton lieu de
vacances quand même c'est vrai alors
Denis Brogniart bonsoir bonsoir Denis si
vous répondez bien à toutes les
questions de Thierry vous aurez droit à
son bracelet de force qui vous donnera
l'immunité sur le plateau de salaire
Denis je vous dis j'ai toujours rêvé de
faire Koh-Lanta voilà bon le petit souci
c'est que vous avez vu mon physique j'ai
pas un physique pour faire Koh-Lanta à
la limite j'ai le physique d'un mec qui
revient de Koh-Lanta
sauf le bronzage oui ça c'est sûr 20
candidats au départ un seul à l'arrivée
des coups bas des alliances des ennemis
prêts à tout même de la perte de poids
bah finalement le Koh-Lanta c'est un peu
ce qui a vécu François Hollande avant
d'être président de la République
alors Denis Brian vous dites cette
émission permet aux anonymes de vivre
des choses incroyables alors attention
Denis ce que c'est exactement le domaine
discours que daesh faut faire attention
Luc c'est le 12e passage de Luc Ferry
alors vous savez quoi Luc j'ai fait une
petite carte de fidélité voilà
un petit coup de tampon
[Applaudissements]
il est mignon en plus
ça me fait plaisir et vous savez quoi la
13e est offerte avec un kiroyal c'est
quand même pas de la merde
rassurez nous lui vous n'êtes pas ici
pour nous faire une dictée non ça va
vous avez peur évidemment en plus ça
aurait été con de la faire aujourd'hui
parce que la semaine prochaine on reçoit
Nabilla
ça aurait pu être beaucoup plus drôle
Luc Ferry vous êtes un intellectuel
alors je rappelle quand même ce que
c'est qu'un intellectuel c'est une
personne dont l'activité repose sur
l'exercice de l'esprit qui s'engage dans
la sphère publique pour faire part de
ses analyses de ces points de vue sur
les sujets les plus variés voilà dans
les médias on appelle ça un intellectuel
dans un bar on appelle ça un poivron
Audrey Lamy bonsoir bonsoir je voudrais
vraiment je l'adore alors pour ceux qui
voilà qui se posent la question non vous
n'avez aucun lien de parenté ni avec
André Lamy ni avec l'ami Ricoré non mais
c'est vrai et puis bon en tout cas très
bonne nouvelle voilà Thierry on a parlé
vous attendez un heureux événement bon
on rassure les téléspectateurs ce n'est
pas Cédric de scènes de ménage de papa
non sauf si jamais à la naissance le
gamin est métisse
en tout cas vous savez que si vous
accouchez sur le plateau c'est un peu
comme dans un avion vous et votre enfant
vous serez VIP non Salut les terriens et
vous aurez un kir royal offert
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
[Musique]
Luc Ferry
si aujourd'hui François Hollande devait
être un sujet de philo ça serait lequel
peut-on avoir raison contre les faits ou
faut-il oublier les conneries du passé
pour se donner vers l'avenir
évidemment le deuxième sujet mais
clair Audrey en 2015 vous avez été à la
fiche de quatre films et à la télé tous
les jours dans scène de ménage ça fait
quoi d'être la caméra au féminin
elle est dégueulasse cette question
pas de travail pas d'électricité pas de
nourriture pas de rapport sexuel en fait
Koh-Lanta c'est un mélange de Chabbat et
du Ramadan
Thierry j'ai pas le temps il y a trop
d'invités là on a un plateau qui est
incroyable Nabilla aymeric Caron pierre
Ménez c'est le top 3 du classement des
gens les plus détestés de France voilà
il manque plus que Dieudonné et François
Hollande et on était au Congo non
heureusement il y a MHD petite pépite
durable
[Applaudissements]
MHD le créateur de l'afro trap l'afro
trap c'est un mélange de musique afro et
de rap français voilà c'est un peu comme
les Magic System mais avec des papiers
alors votre nom de scène MHD vient de
votre prénom moi Ahmed et vous avez
gardé les consonnes et ça donne MHD très
très bonne idée parce que si vous aviez
gardé les voyelles ça donnait et là ça
faisait plus ça faisait plus handicapés
que rappeur
Pierre Ménès notre expert a quel âge le
foot quand même en plus en plus Pierre
il est il est trilingue français anglais
Ribéry c'est très fort
ces mots ça c'est ce que j'aime bien
c'est j'ai regardé en disant il s'est
clashé plus de fois que Georges Marchais
dans toute sa vie il cache tout le monde
les joueurs les entraîneurs les
dirigeants chaque si la Fatou existé
dans le foot tu serais mort
pierre c'est un très grand sportif non
non c'est pas une vanne non non non
c'est vrai c'est ta meilleure vanne non
non non
c'est pas
pierre je le souhaite beaucoup au tennis
tu joues super bien au foot on sauve
qu'avec pierre un petit pont on appelle
ça l'Arc de Triomphe
Nabilla Nabilla je préfère voilà vous
prévenir il y a des détecteurs de métaux
à l'entrée du studio mais c'est pas
contre vous c'est à cause du plan
Vigipirate nous on y est pour rien c'est
bon on va en parler comme ça on sera
débarrassé oui il y a eu cette fameuse
nuit du 6 novembre oui il y a eu un coup
de couteau mais voilà vous avez dit s'il
y avait une louche j'aurais pris une
louche
ah c'est ballot parce que ça aurait pas
fini en prison mais un Top Chef donc ça
c'est quand même
[Applaudissements]
la Villa beaucoup de gens prennent pour
une idiote et franchement moi je suis
pas je suis pas d'accord parce que vous
avez quand même écrit deux livres et
écrire deux livres quand on en a lu
qu'un seul c'est quand même vachement
bien
et juste pour terminer ça c'est pas une
vanne en fait je cherche des auteurs
parce que quand même Nabilla quand la
vue je lui ai dit qu'elle était écrouée
à Versailles elle a répondu quoi au
château de Versailles
je peux pas faire le
[Applaudissements]
la proposition est ouverte
ce soir c'est la soirée des auteurs
Nabilla il Mike Caron est chez pivot là
c'est Pierre si tu as fait la préface de
l'album Panini pour l'Euro tu nous le
dis il y a pas de
Aymeric sachant que vous défendez les
animaux on a fait très très attention ce
soir j'ai laissé ma veste en cuir chez
moi et Thierry a pas mis son slip
léopard donc ça c'est ça quand même
c'est Florent Pagny qui te l'a prêté
alors l'année dernière vous aviez
participé à Fort Boyard voilà alors
qu'on met le traite les animaux ça vous
dérange par contre qu'on fasse courir
des kilomètres et des kilomètres des
nains sans les autoriser à parler ça
vous vous en foutez complètement
Aymeric il est tellement végétalien
qu'il a retiré de son vocabulaire les
expressions et mon cul c'est du poulet
et ah tu aimes ça [__] voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs je suis pour vous
poser les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous poser
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas à clasher les joueurs de
foot de manière très violente aussi sur
Twitter si ça veut dire vous seriez
aussi virulent
et moi Caron en tant que vegetalien
qu'est-ce qui vous choque le plus de
voir un poulet sur égorger dans un
abattoir ou une carotte utilisée dans
comme sextoys dans un porno
le premier le poulet MHD MHD pour pour
vous c'est important que les gens
retiennent vos paroles mais aussi vos
chorégraphies de sur vos chansons
de faire la Macarena sans déconner
et pour terminer Nabilla Nabilla en 2011
alors vous étiez hôtesse sur le stand de
Peugeot vous aviez été élu Miss Auto
Salon voilà d'après vous c'est grâce à
vos pare-chocs ou à votre intérieur
cuillère
d'avoir sur le même plateau les rois de
la nuit parisienne des années 80 Thierry
Ardisson et Peter et Sloane
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Paul Gaultier Thierry Ardisson
réunis alors je sais pas lequel a le
plus de dossiers sur l'autre en tout cas
ce qui s'est passé au Palace doit rester
dans les chiottes du palace très
important
Jean-Paul Gaultier bonsoir bonsoir alors
bon si vous êtes venus ce soir pour me
proposer de défiler avec vous ça sera
grand plaisir par contre je préfère vous
prévenir je marche comme un canard et si
j'ai des talons ça sera plus Daisy que 4
mots
en tout cas bravo Jean-Paul
contrairement à Madonna 40 ans de
carrière et pas une ride ça peut
s'applaudir très fort
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que j'aime bien chez Jean-Paul
c'est qui surprend toujours dans ses
défilés Loana vous aviez défilé pour lui
il y a une dizaine d'années il y a 3 ans
c'était Nabilla donc en fait on dit que
les candidats de la téléréalité ils sont
cons non il faut juste défiler pour JPG
quand même mais c'est vrai non
mais alors Jean-Paul vous êtes ami avec
tout le monde si vous avez un répertoire
c'est le 11 août vous avez le numéro de
Madonna ou pas ouais ok Catherine
Deneuve
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir alors donc Thierry la femme à
barbe c'est fait le nain beg c'est fait
le premier homme qui a fait du visage
c'est fait le 24 sexuel c'est bon alors
tenez Inès je vous donne la petite carte
de fidélité Salut les Terriens d'accord
vous êtes ici chez
vous
vous revenez vraiment quand vous voulez
un quai Royal est offert alors moi ce
que je vous propose Thierry pour la
semaine prochaine j'ai une chinoise qui
s'est fait greffer des nichons dans le
dos
ça sert à rien mais au moins elle peut
dormir sur le ventre et sinon j'ai un
Syrien qui cherche à rester dans son
pays mais il faut pas tarder à l'inviter
parce que ça sent le roussi quand même
très drôle
[Applaudissements]
alors Inès Pro vous êtes né homme et à
l'âge de 18 ans vous avez subi
l'opération pour changer de sexe voilà
bravo parce qu'il faut avoir des
couilles pour le enfin
il faut
Loana bonsoir alors c'est le grand
retour de louana vous êtes amincy vous
avez changé de look en politique on
appelle ça faire une François Hollande
alors n'allez pas nous décevoir s'il
vous plaît vraiment
[Applaudissements]
voilà Loana c'est la première star issue
de la téléréalité c'est à dire que vous
êtes la première qui a gagné l'argent en
foutant rien de ses journées mais en
l'assument totalement et on le montrant
à tout le monde quand même love story et
puis bon on revient il y a eu l'histoire
de la piscine mais moi je m'en fous de
ce qui s'est passé mais ce qui me choque
c'est pas ce que vous avez fait de moi
je peux comprendre tout seul mais ce qui
m'a choqué c'est que personne n'ait
changé l'eau franchement je trouve ça
dégueulasse
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
inestro Inès RAW quand on passe sur la
table d'opération avant un changement de
sexe est-ce que c'est vrai que le
chirurgien comme dans Qui veut gagner
des millions il vous demande si c'est
votre dernier mot
Jean-Paul Gaultier c'est vrai que quand
vous avez proposé un Nabilla d'être
votre égérie avant d'accepter elle a
taper le mot égérie sur google pour
vérifier
absolument pas absolument absolument pas
et pour terminer Loana alors Loana
pendant quelques temps vous avez eu les
cheveux roses cette équipe de coiffeur
mon petit poney
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
évidemment vous le savez c'est pour
rendre hommage au centre de la déconne
de la fête et de l'humour Éric Ciotti
alors
ça va Eric ça va très bien chauffez vous
sur le côté j'arrive dans 2 minutes je
m'occupe des autres d'abord Patrick
Sébastien 40 ans de télé il a connu la
ménagère de 50 ans quand elle en avait
10 ça peut ça peut dire très très fort
Patrick Sébastien animateur artiste
écrivain comédien Patrick sous César
festifs potache c'est quand même à
découvrir talent sans lui on n'aurait
pas connu Dupontel du jardin Shirley
Dino Jeff panacloc bon Shirley Dino ça
aurait pas été une grosse paire non sur
le point auditif parce que la meuf elle
parle en ultrason je suis allé pas
humoriste et dresseuse de dauphin marine
Patrick vous avez dit j'étais déjà
ringard à 25 ans vous avez d'autres
points communs avec François Hollande
[Applaudissements]
on en a plein
en tout cas Patrick bienvenue à Salut
les Terriens mettez-vous à l'aide soyez
détendu faites comme chez vous et puis
vous avez vu il y a un groupe si vous
voulez jouer ils peuvent faire ce que
vous voulez les grément bon évidemment à
part casser du noir alors
Santa du groupe iPhone iPhone bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue Bienvenue merci comme
ça deux fois ça va être bien faire chier
ouais j'ai tout répéter comme ça deux
fois ça ça a bien faire chier
on Santa vous êtes la leader du groupe
iPhone iPhone voilà alors parce que
Samsung c'était trop grillé et non mais
c'est vrai que c'est bien de répéter
deux fois iPhone parce que ça rentre
mieux c'est vrai que d'ailleurs Eric
vous devriez faire ça dans votre partie
les républicains républicains on essaye
non mais parce que ça permettrait de
faire la différence entre les
républicains républicains comme vous et
les républicains démocrates comme Juppé
donc Santa vous êtes originaire de Nice
et vous avez dit Nice c'est la ville
idéale pour composer tu m'étonnes avec
le nombre de vues à moitié sourds tu
peux répéter préfère
Éric Ciotti bonsoir bonsoir je suis très
content de mettre enfin un visage sur le
côté obscur de Nicolas Sarkozy
Eric vous êtes député les républicains
alors vous savez que vous êtes le seul à
quoi vous êtes présenté à la primaire
absolument même la femme de ménage elle
a fait non non mais vous avez vu la
liste Thierry ils sont 11 candidats en
tout cas si vous devez choisir celui qui
a le moins de casseroles locus ça va
être chaud enfin bon en tout cas il
paraît qu'Eric Ciotti il est tellement
contre la mixité que vous comptez
remplacer les olives noires par des
olives vertes dans la salade niçoise
Éric en tant que président du conseil
départemental des Alpes-Maritimes ou
pousser un coup de gueule contre les
flux migratoires incontrôlés et je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous voilà non
vraiment moi je le pense faudrait fermer
les frontières mais entre le 1er juillet
et le 30 août comme ça plus d'allemand
puis de Hollandais et plus d'anglais sur
la Côte d'Azur qui nous vole notre rosée
et nos salades niçoise
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Santa vous avez longtemps fait vos
répétitions avec votre groupe dans le
dans le salon de vos parents c'est vrai
c'est vrai et du coup vos parents ils
habitaient dans le garage
[Rires]
et ericsiotti
Eric vous êtes l'auteur d'une
proposition de loi visant à lutter
contre l'absentéisme scolaire et du coup
quand vous regardez NRJ12 vous avez pas
le sentiment d'avoir échoué
un petit peu un peu
et pour terminer Patrick Sébastien vous
aviez sorti un livre dans lequel vous
vous évoquez vos expériences dans des
clubs échangistes alors sans citer de
nom est-ce que sur ce plateau il y a des
gens que vous avez connus dans voilà non
pas de quoi
ma liberté de penser Thierry moi par
contre je sais pas qui chante cette
chanson mais
c'est qui c'est l'autre condo
en tout cas ce soir Thierry on a un
plateau de gâteau de ce soir
Florent Pagny et Diam's
mais bon commençons d'abord par celui
qui allait les idées de Brice
hortefeuille avec le physique d'un
comédien des Feux de l'Amour Geoffroy
Didier
Geoffroy Didier avocat au barreau de New
York et de Paris la classe si vous aviez
pas été droite des Sky aurait fait appel
à vous et s'il n'avait pas été con il
aurait été président
Geoffroy Didier fondateur de la droite
forte alors là il y a un moment où ça va
être compliqué parce que entre la droite
la droite forte la droite dure l'extrême
droite bon en tout cas a priori la
droite fort tout est relatif parce que
pour Mike Tyson c'est une droite molle
en tout cas Geoffroy vous êtes membre de
l'Association des Amis Nicolas Sarkozy
si vous aviez monté l'association des
ennemis de Sarkozy je pense qu'il y
aurait eu plus de d'adhérents
Florent Pagny
bonsoir j'adore Florent Pagny parce que
c'est le l'homme qui chante ce qui pense
voilà un problème avec la presse qui
chante presque qui coule me casse les
couilles un problème avec le fiscal avec
le fils ou ma liberté de penser bon on
espère juste que vous aurez pas de
problème d'érection ça c'est le
en tout cas Thierry vous l'avez dit
Florent Pagny c'est aussi une gueule et
un look alors après toutes les coupes et
teintures que vous avez faites vous avez
encore tous vos cheveux Florence c'est
quand même incroyable alors je te donne
le tuyau j'ai fait des implants c'est
vrai ça t'arrivera aussi
alors attention
c'est la technique cheveux par cheveux
et ça marche très bien en tout cas
Florent vous avez dit j'ai toujours
habitué les gens à ne pas être coiffé de
la même manière en tout cas c'est con
parce que le fisc vous reconnaît
toujours et
le style de Florent voilà vous l'avez
dit Thierry voilà c'est vrai que bon je
sais pas qui est le styliste de Florence
ça doit être le zoo de Beauval
non mais en planète il y a l'impression
de regarder les reines du shopping voilà
mon dressing les crocodiles il l'appelle
papa donc arrête on arrête Augustin
trappnard
c'est la famille c'est la maison c'est
Canal+ voilà vous venez avec un nouveau
projet d'émission qui s'appelle 21 cm
bravo les sous-entendus
moyenne d'un roman qui paraît si la
vôtre c'est un roman moi c'est un livre
de poche et 10 18 et
Thierry c'est un Larousse mais en 12
volumes ça je tiens à le préciser mais
en tout cas Augustin c'est un gros
bosseur radio le matin télé le soir il
dort 4h par nuit ça commence à se voir
on le rappelle Augustin il a 19 ans
de la fin de l'année
bonsoir Samia la première humoriste à
jouer sur scène avec le voile depuis les
ventes bien entendu
pour faire disparaître tous les
malentendus liés au dernier événements
récents vous n'êtes pas une catho droite
qui revient de vacances et non parce que
voilà Samia vous êtes une femme vous
êtes musulmane et vous êtes humoriste et
vous êtes ici pour nous dire lequel de
trois est le plus handicapant tout
simplement
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Geoffroy Didier Geoffroy à l'UMP vous
étiez rémunéré 8000 euros pour être
l'assistant de Brice Hortefeux à part
lui trouver des blagues racistes c'était
quoi votre boulot
ça c'est du temps ancien samyo Roseman
Samia avec votre look multicolore vous
attirez plus quoi le public les ophtalmo
ou les contrôles de police
et pour terminer Augustin Trapenard
Augustin votre émission sur Canal
s'appelle 21 cm votre émission sur
France Inter s'appelle boomerang c'est
des types d'émission ou une description
de votre anatomie on peut des deux on
commence à voir très bien bon ben super
un petit débrie de mission de la semaine
dernière la semaine dernière on savait
Geoffroy Didier l'un des 138 candidats à
la primaire républicaine et
malheureusement on croit Twitter
Geoffroy n'a pas beaucoup convaincu
pourquoi bah comment témoigne ce message
qui dit Geoffroy Didier ce soir dans slt
tel qu'il est des idées de vieux dans un
corps de jeune
non mais c'est con voilà des des idées
de de vieux dans un corps de jeune parce
que l'inverse des idées de jeunes dans
un corps de vieux c'était tiré Ardisson
c'est quand même ballot
je suis le soleil de ta vie connard
[Applaudissements]
très beau plateau ce soir Thierry
Christophe Dechavanne bonsoir bonsoir
Christophe alors désolé par avance parce
que voilà pour votre Vivement Dimanche
Michel Drucker il vous avez installé
dans un beau canapé rouge voilà
vous savez canal est une chaîne avec des
petits moyens et encore on a eu de la
chance parce que sur France 3 c'est des
tabourets pourris donc pas non plus non
mais sur le plateau d'ailleurs vous avez
pleuré en voyant vos filles dans une
vidéo attention non non mais c'est
c'était super touchant non non mais
vraiment non mais en plus pour tout vous
dire je vous explique la scène moi
j'étais chez moi j'avais coupé le son je
me suis dit [__] Drucker il a
séquestré les gamines de Chavanne il
demande une rançon
bonsoir Hubert Védrine des Affaires
étrangères ça veut dire qu'il a
tellement voyagé qu'il a cinq passeports
un par continent puis ça veut surtout
dire que vous étiez le meilleur plan
pour amener de l'herbe de Jamaïque sans
être emmerdé pourquoi on l'a pas connu
plutôt Thierry [__]
un écolo convaincu voilà moi le mot
convaincu ça me fait toujours marrer
parce que ça veut dire qu'il y a des
écolos moyennement convaincus ouais non
je sais pas si le diesel pollue vraiment
mais dans le doute je vais prendre une
voiture hybride voilà vous voyez Hubert
Christophe Dechavanne aussi il est écolo
il recycle les vieux chanteurs
[Applaudissements]
Nawel Madani notre petit rayon de soleil
si c'est la nouvelle prof de maths moi
je m'inscris tout de suite
danseuse qui est devenu humoriste tout
le chemin inverse de Bigard quand il a
fait Danse avec les stars non mais bon
le gros drame de votre enfance Nawel
c'est que vous avez été brûlé petite par
une friteuse voilà c'est le problème
qu'on vit en Belgique tu serais né en
Norvège tu serais pris un saumon dans la
gueule
puis je tiens vraiment à le préciser
Nawel elle va jouer le 12 juillet à
l'Olympia foncé moi j'ai vu le spectacle
au Trianon c'était mortel elle est drôle
et danse elle a des danseurs sur scène
Thierry moi si jamais je ramène des
danseurs sur scène ils vont croire que
c'est une manif des intermittents les
gens c'est pas possible spinnawel il y a
le passage au Jamel Comedy Club qui fait
partie des émissions qui remplissent les
salles de spectacle avec qu'on me
demande qu'à en rire mais je pense que
la meilleure filière ça reste quand même
le Parti socialiste parce que ça fait un
mois et demi qui sont complets place de
la République et ça c'est très très très
bien
je suis ici pour vous poser les
questions trop con que Thierry Ardisson
n'a pas voulu vous poser attention quand
même attention Christophe Dechavanne
Christophe est-ce que c'est vrai que
pour acheter André tête de bois vous
placez les malades de Parkinson devant
parce qu'ils applaudissent mieux
heureusement que j'ai dit attention
Hubert
vous êtes écolo depuis longtemps ou
c'est depuis que vous avez vu Pamela
Anderson à l'Assemblée nationale
et pour terminer Nawel Madani votre
spectacle s'appelle c'est moi la plus
belge alors bon en ce moment c'est pas
hyper hyper vendeur mais et vous avez
passé votre permis de conduire à
Molenbeek ce n'est pas trop dur de faire
des créneaux entre deux voitures piégées
très bon plateau ce soir Thierry
Vincent Lagaf' Vincent je l'adore c'est
l'idole de ma jeunesse tous les soirs
j'étais devant l'or à l'appel Le Bigdil
sur TF1 et j'avais toujours cette même
question où trouve-t-il toute cette
énergie et ses costumes ridicules
non mais vous avez été l'un des premiers
à voir des vos propres la danseuse dans
vos émissions Les Gafettes vont appeler
Thierry desgafettes j'adorais les gars
faites ça ça valait pas Titia Italia
enfin italien et Titia qu'on embrasse
d'ailleurs comme comme toutes les autres
serveuses du Buffalo Grill de
Neuilly-sur-Marne
[Applaudissements]
et puis la gaffe les plus jeunes ne le
savent pas mais c'est un homme de télé
mais c'est aussi un homme de scène il a
démarré par ça et aujourd'hui vous vous
interdisez d'ailleurs de refaire du one
man show alors je savais pas qu'on
pouvait faire ça avec on pouvait se
faire interdire de casino mais de scène
je savais pas de non mais c'est vrai
faut absolument mettre au courant Cauet
hein Thierry
alors vous venez aujourd'hui Vincent
parce que vous avez ouvert une école de
Flyboard d'overboard et de jetpack à
Cavalaire-sur-Mer c'est super alors le
Flyboard j'explique rapidement c'est
apprendre aux gens à voler sur l'eau
Jésus a marché sur l'eau vous vous volez
au-dessus de l'eau alors s'il y a des
mecs qui arrivent avec des poteaux et
des clous un conseil coulé
Thierry Braillard bonsoir
elle était facile
il y en a un des deux qui a pris un
pseudo et l'autre qui aurait dû en
prendre un et non enfin un mec de gauche
à ça fait plaisir Thierry parce que on a
eu que des mecs de droite là c'est
derrière ce mène j'ai failli passer pour
un mec de gauche j'ai une réputation à
tenir quand même alors vous êtes le
secrétaire d'État chargé des sports et
c'est vrai que bosser au ministère des
Sports sous François Hollande ça doit
pas être évident à assumer c'est comme
bosser au ministère de la Solidarité
sous Sarkozy
c'est en tout cas vous faites partie des
des fidèles du président et vous avez
dit Hollande doit rassembler et je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec vous Thierry
il doit rassembler et ses affaires et
partir très douce
[Applaudissements]
Natacha Polony bonsoir
il y a des soirées qu'on commence
beaucoup plus mal tirer alors moi je
propose un truc on éteint la lumière on
se met tout nu on voit ce qui se passe
deuxième passage de l'année dans Salut
les Terriens alors bon d'habitude ça
partir du troisième passage donc je vous
fais la petite carte de fidélité Salut
les Terriens voilà hop un coup de tampon
et au troisième il y a un quai Royal
offert donc voilà ça c'est le petit
cadeau de la
marinaquet bonsoir Marina en fait c'est
elle qui me fait le plus flipper ce soir
pour tout vous dire parce qu'elle a
caché Yann Moix et Véronique Sanson un
conseil Thierry ne vous fiez pas super
cool avec eux
en fait c'est la Jean-Luc Mélenchon de
la chanson française sauf que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'a pas de jolis minois et
Marina vous avez été révélé à au grand
public grâce à l'émission La France a un
incroyable talent c'est sûr que la
France a un incroyable talent bah c'est
dur pour une chanteuse parce que de
passer entre un mec qui avale des sabres
et un autre qui fait des peintures avec
son pénis en tout cas vous avez une très
belle voix marina et je vais même vous
dire c'est vraiment un compliment la
première fois que je vous ai entendu à
la radio je me suis dit et je chante
vachement bien cette Américaine et en
fait non vous êtes française alors que
c'est vrai qu'on entend Carla Bruni on
se dit bah tiens
voilà et
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson
n'a pas voulu vous poser Thierry
Braillard alors Thierry vous êtes sous
la tutelle de Patrick Canet moi je mon
twitter c'est Thierry Ardisson du coup
vous aussi après le boulot vous avez
droit à une coupe de champagne un gros
pets
Marina Kaye Marina votre première
chanson parue en 2014 s'intitule
homeless ce qui signifie sans abri
est-ce que c'est un hommage à tous ceux
qui n'ont pas de toi ou c'est juste pour
François Hollande en 2017
et pour terminer Natacha Polony Natacha
sur Paris Première vous présentez
l'émission polonium
vous avez choisi ce type parce que
imodium ça faisait trop chier
alors pas de débrief cette semaine
Thierry par contre voilà juste une
petite mise au point on est d'accord
c'est vous qui avez lancé le magazine
Entrevue il y a 20 ans que là vous avez
face à vous un grand patron de presse
qui sort un nouveau magazine ça
s'appelle Rebel santé voilà ça c'est le
journal de Thierry Ardisson
[Applaudissements]
mais si c'est vous Thierry je sais pas
moi du tout des fois je vous jure on
s'emmerde à chercher des vannes là et
tombe toute seule comme ça on a comment
c'est ça la rédac voilà rebelle santé
alors voilà pour tous ceux qui prennent
des médicaments mais qui s'en battent
les couilles des dosages voilà
exactement
[Applaudissements]
là ce soir il y en a pour tout le monde
capillairement c'est au top blond brun
brushing bouclette ce soir c'est plus
une émission c'est une pub L'Oréal
Roselyne Bachelot bonsoir bon Roselyne
je l'adore elle a quasiment réussi à
nous faire oublier qu'elle avait bossé
avec Sarkozy c'est très Florent non mais
depuis que vous faites plus de politique
Rosine vous êtes devenu ce qu'on appelle
une bonne cliente voilà vous êtes
capable de déclamer un superbe poème et
une blague de cul derrière en fait
Roselyne c'est le chaînon manquant entre
Luchini Jean-Marie Bigard
mais ce que j'aime par dessus tout est
Roselyne c'est que elle a peur de rien
quitte à se faire des ennemis Rosine
vous êtes en procès avec Raphaël Nadal
que vous avez accusé dopage dalle il a
tellement mal pris qui et qui vous a
attaqué c'est pas comme si on s'en
doutait pas enfin il a un bras gauche et
la cuisse d'une vache non mais tu
regardes son biceps donc quand même
c'est bah voilà non mais c'est comme si
moi j'accusais Balkany détourné de
l'argent et qui m'attaquait pour
diffamation
max Boublil bonsoir
Julian Perretta il s'appelle Giuliani
nous vient de loin s'il avait le monde
entier à ses trous on aurait eu Julian
Assange heureusement il n'a que des
gamines de 15 ans qu'il poursuivent dans
la rue c'est Julian Perretta mes
[Applaudissements]
en 2009 vous avez chanté sur la tournée
Beyoncé c'est la classe en 2015 vous
avez joué dans le spectacle de Kev Adams
et vous êtes ici pour nous dire qui
utilise le plus de démêlant et de fer à
lisser voilà Alexandra Lamy bonsoir
Alexandra la classe sur TF1 avec après
moi le bonheur vous avez cartonné vous
incarniez une maman atteinte d'un cancer
et vous avez accepté de jouer sans
maquillage bravo voilà quand on sait
qu'une semaine sans maquillage de
Roselyne Bachelot c'est un phoque de
sauver
et Thierry c'est un ours blanc voilà
j'ai même pas demandé à être maquillée
bon Alexandra bon on va pas se mentir
voilà il y a des petits sujets sensibles
chez vous comme Jean Dujardin votre sœur
mais chez tout le monde il y a des
sujets sensibles Roselyne c'est les
vaccins Julian c'est ses cheveux non
Thierry c'est son âge les partouze les
rides canal son poids l'alcool voilà
c'est il y a des
[Applaudissements]
mois le premier moi j'ai pas envie qu'en
tant que stagiaire on sèche toute ma vie
privée voilà vous connaissez le problème
ce qui se passe à la photocopieuse doit
rester à la photocopieuse voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Julian perrettable Julian votre papa est
italien et votre maman est irlandaise du
coup ça donne quoi le tiramisu à la
Guinness c'est bon ou pas
Alexandra Lamy aujourd'hui vous vivez à
Londres si c'est ni pour les impôts ni
pour la météo quel intérêt
Roselyne Bachelot Roselyne vous avez dit
entrevoir une [__] et un cerveau que
vous avez choisi d'avoir un cerveau ça
veut dire que Nabilla a une [__]
[Applaudissements]
très très beau plateau ce soir Thierry
Laura de mon jumeau pour ceux qui vous
connaîtraient pas encore vous avez
commencé à jouer dans le métro alors ça
c'est pas grave c'est l'inverse qui est
plus relou puisqu'il est ce qui est
drôle c'est que quand tu es humoriste
c'est qu'en fonction des villes où tu
joues bah tu t'adaptes forcément suivant
la tournée des phrases de ton spectacle
par exemple je sais pas au hasard à
Béziers tu peux pas dire est-ce qu'il y
a des noirs des Arabes dans la salle bah
non il y en a pas
du Carlier rose ça fait plaisir de vous
revoir Guy entre autres parce que vous
avez perdu du poids vous êtes en pleine
forme ça c'est cool il a perdu 100 kg
c'est quand même énorme
en disant en disant 100 kg c'est énorme
100 kg ça fait moi plus tout le chiffre
de Thierry
plus trois pièces de champagne de
Thierry c'est quand même extraordinaire
non alors Guy vous venez ce soir pour
nous parler d'un livre sur Mathieu
Valbuena qui contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser n'est pas un livre de
poche
vous avez écrit le livre qui veut tuer
Matthieu Valbuena et chez Laurent
Ruquier la semaine dernière vous avez
balancé que dans la vidéo de la sextape
c'était pas avec sa femme qui couchait
franchement Guy vous nous avez spoilé le
livre qui veut tuer Mathieu Valbuena
c'est sa femme évidemment
tout ça pour créer un buzz faut faire un
plus gros buzz par exemple alors moi ce
que je veux savoir il est avec qui
est-ce que je parle une blonde un roux
de Black un poney dites-nous
mais tu le sais toi qui veux tuer
Mathieu Valbonne
m'a dit avant l'émission surtout te
laisse pas entraîner dans les questions
à la con je suis sûr qu'hardisson va te
demander avec qui il est c'est pas
Thierry qui le demande c'est moi non non
mais non j'ai 50 2 4 5 ans bon bah
d'accord allez bon il est pas avec sa
femme
en tout cas dit vous avez dit le foot
est devenu le reflet de ce que j'appelle
la France qui pue clinique
communautariste intolérantes grossière
suspicieux défiante blasée merci
beaucoup Guy ça me permet une très belle
transition avec notre prochaine invité
Robert Ménard bonsoir
n'attendez pas de moi quelconque
moquerie ou jugement sur votre carrière
vous faites des choses extraordinaires
pour votre ville déjà grâce à vous
maintenant on s'est placé Béziers sur
une carte ça c'est vachement bien non
mais c'est vrai que en plus la police
municipale de Béziers est connue pour
chasser les SDF du centre-ville alors ça
c'est très bien Robert parce que c'est
les mecs ils dorment par terre et nous
après on se prend les pieds dans leurs
jambes [__] non mais vraiment je
trouve ça dégueulasse il y a eu mais
c'est vrai
non il y a eu le cas Black M aussi à
Verdun je suis d'accord avec vous voilà
moi non plus je voulais pas qui chante à
Verdun pas pour les mêmes raisons parce
que moi je pense que c'est franchement
de la merde franchement tiens ils
avaient entendu une alarme de Kangoo
sans déconner
vous savez qu'il a chanté à Béziers
c'est pas vrai je l'ai même autorisé
figure moi je n'aurais pas laissé
chanter à Béziers non plus alors
et vous avez dit aussi Robert j'assume
je ne veux pas que Béziers deviennent la
capitale du kebab c'est combien sont
rien à voir avec notre culture et je
suis d'accord aussi retour au bon vieux
jambon beurre c'est vrai pour ceux qui
mangent pas de jambon allez vous faire
[__] c'est vrai non pas les musulmans
les vegan c'est pire parce que ceux qui
dictent ta loi c'est pas Dieu c'est
aymeric Caron [__]
[Applaudissements]
la question que j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est pas pourquoi c'est comment et je
sais ce que vous allez me dire Robert
vous êtes pas raciste et tout est
relatif Franck Ribéry pour lui il est
pas con donc vous voyez tout est relatif
voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est la relativité et puis voilà il y a
votre femme Emmanuel Duverger et qui
vous dites former un couple très
fusionnel alors je veux pas briser votre
couple proverbe et fusionner le
fusionnel vous êtes marié avec elle et
pourtant elle a gardé son nom de jeune
fille donc même votre femme elle veut
pas porter votre nom Robert
[Applaudissements]
sur ce je trouve ça assez minable cette
dernière remarque pourquoi parce que je
trouve ça assez minable
en tout cas on va remonter l'ambiance
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Laura demande alors Laura sur votre
ancien affiche de spectacle vous teniez
d'une main une sucette et de l'autre une
cigarette c'était pour prévenir le
public que pendant votre spectacle il
est interdit de fumer et de sucer
c'est ça l'icarlier Guy Franck Ribéry
avait porté plainte contre vous c'est
vrai qu'à cause des énormes fautes de
français la plainte avait été jugée il
receva par le tribunal
Robert Ménard il y a un truc que je
comprends pas chez vous vous êtes
catholique pratiquant à quel moment vous
avez loupé la phrase tu aimeras ton
prochain comme toi-même
viens voir les comédiens
les musiciens c'est pour nos invités
évidemment voilà les comédiens sont de
diennes les magiciens Éric Antoine les
à vous de nous dire si vous jouez du
piano ou de la flûte du pipeau
Antoine on écrit ensemble des petites
bêtises des fois pour Michel Drucker
Michel si tu nous regardes on t'embrasse
et puis je tenais à dévoiler ce soir une
sorte de petit secret la cantine de
Michel Drucker est beaucoup trop petite
au Studio Gabriel et du coup il nous est
déjà arrivé avec Eric de manger de la
piémontaise sur le canapé de Vivement
Dimanche voilà on peut faire un zoom ou
pas donc voilà je tiens à m'excuser
auprès de Michel les miettes de pain
c'était nous par contre les croûtes
c'était chez là alors
[Applaudissements]
donc ce soir c'est un petit peu
particulier voilà Eric je le connais
bien Vincent Dedienne on se connait un
petit peu on a partagé la même loge à
l'Olympia
et Nathalie koscius alors là je vous
sens un petit peu tendu vous inquiétez
pas j'ai la photo j'ai aucune photo de
nous deux par contre j'ai tout filmé je
t'enverrai la vidéo alors
Eric Antoine Eric vous êtes le plus
grand invité de Salut les Terriens cette
saison 2 m 07 alors vous n'êtes pas là
en invité du samedi 20h entre la femme à
barbe et l'aveugle qui a fait le tour du
monde non non 2 m 07 c'est
impressionnant et c'est ça veut dire que
même assis vous êtes encore plus grand
que Manuel Valls et puis vous êtes
magicien et humoriste un peu comme
jamais le bon sauf que lui Jamel il fait
toujours le même tour il fait
disparaître sa main dans sa poche ça
c'est super
[Applaudissements]
plus pourquoi
à Nathalie
quelque chose c'est vrai
c'est le tour où tu fais disparaître son
passé Sarkozy tout
fait de la magie mais pas des miracles
non
mais oui
102e Vincent Dedienne vous êtes
humoriste et vous êtes originaire de
Macron alors je vais pas me moquer de
Macron Thierry déjà parce que Vincent le
fait très bien sur scène et puis surtout
non mais c'est vrai dans ton spectacle
et tout moi je suis originaire
Roissy-en-Brie en Seine-et-Marne
et honnêtement un mec de Roissy-en-Brie
qui se moquerait d'un mec de Macron ça
le fait pas c'est un peu comme le cancer
qui se moquerait du sida c'est vrai non
mais c'est vrai la fin est globalement
la même mais quitte à mourir autant se
marrer un petit peu avant aux parents
ont découvert vous étiez gay en venant
vous voir sur scène c'est quand même la
double peine chérie notre fils est gay
et en plus il est intermittent
c'est pas grave c'est pas un drame et
tout c'est vrai que vos parents ça
aurait pu être plus graves ils auraient
pu découvrir je sais pas comme les
parents de Titeuf que vous étiez pas
drôle et bien
bonsoir alors cette semaine rien sur la
politique Thierry parce que la semaine
dernière j'ai fait Robert Ménard et trop
d'emmerde voilà donc il t'aime beaucoup
Robert j'irai pas en vacances à Béziers
donc voilà donc en tout cas je parlerai
pas de vos idées pas de votre vie privée
donc NKM vous êtes né un 14 mai et ce
soir vous êtes à Salut les Terriens
voilà si ça va trop loin dites le moi
Thierry je parle
lors de l'élection régionale vous avez
vous aviez voulu un petit peu soutenir
Valérie Pécresse dans l'Essonne et vous
avez fait la rime suivante Pécresse
c'est moins de stress c'est bien oui
c'est non non mais pourquoi pas pourquoi
on dit que trouver des slogans c'est un
métier avec Fillon vous avez quoi
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson toujours pas voulu vous
poser
Eric Antoine
Eric vous avez été jury dans le
l'émission La France a un incroyable
talent qu'elle tourne vous a le plus
bluffé c'est le mec qui peint avec son
zizi ou le maquillage d'Hélène Segara
Joker et je félicite Thierry de ne pas
avoir posé cette question voilà moi j'ai
refusé j'aime trop Hélène il y a trop de
gens qui l'aiment d'ailleurs
Nathalie koscio Morizet le j'ai lu dans
une interview que le premier geste que
vous faites le matin vous le vend c'est
d'ouvrir en grand votre fenêtre vous
avez d'autres points communs avec Mike
Brant
et pour terminer Vincent Dedienne
Vincent vous avez pas comment on dise
que vous faites du one man show mais
plutôt du seul en scène est-ce que c'est
pareil pour tout par exemple vous dites
pas un fils fucking mais un point dans
les fesses
et celle là il faut répondre
ça fait plaisir merci bah oui mais vous
serez d'accord avec moi je suis un
monsieur Gattaz que il y a plein de
stagiaires qui aiment leur patron ça
doit exister oui vous allez de douter
vous-même
j'espère non mais oui et puis des
patrons qui qui payent leur stagiaires
ça existe ce soir sur le plateau que des
invités qui représentent pierre Gatta
c'est le patrona Natoo les youtubeurs
ils vend le bolloc' les les cheveux gras
mi-longs et non
pierre Gattaz pierre le patron des
patrons si vous êtes la musique on
aurait eu Johnny dommage on a pire
iatase non mais vous avez beaucoup de
points communs avec Johnny monsieur
Gattaz la moindre apparition publique
suscite des hurlements des pleurs des
mouvements de foule bon sauf que Johnny
c'est pour lui faire des câlins vous
voilà et non vous avez vous avez une
très bonne tête c'est vrai il a l'air
on lui donnerait des stocks
alors pierre vous êtes le président du
Medef alors le Medef qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est le mouvement des entreprises de
France une sorte de CGT pour les mecs
qui payent l'ISF
non mais c'est vrai eux quand ils
mangent les merguez elles sont fourrés
au foie gras
en tout cas non mais c'est vrai on a
plus l'image du patron ai par ses
employés alors qu'il y a des employés
qui aiment leur patron comme moi par
exemple j'aime mon patron voilà quand il
y a un problème j'en parle à Thierry
directement il est accessible il est à
l'écoute de bons conseils par exemple il
m'a conseillé de jamais demander
d'augmentation
et je les fais et ça fait un an
en tout cas pierre gataz en 2013 vous
aviez créé des pin's où vous étiez
engagé à créer un million d'emplois en 5
ans pas engagé pas engagé objectif moi
je vous respecte parce que vous avez pas
dit quel pays donc ça jusque-là
on fait des vidéos sur Internet origine
polonaise hébergement YouTube très
important parce que sur youporn vous
auriez pas été invité à saluer les
Terriens mais dans zéro limite la
prochaine émission de Thierry sur D8
Natoo en moyenne vous faites entre 5 et
6 millions de vues par vidéo
pierre c'est l'équivalent du nombre de
chômeurs en France ce qui sur Youtube on
peut pas trafiquer les chiffres
et puis on emmerde toujours les
youtubeurs parce qu'il gagne de l'argent
en faisant des vidéos mais c'est normal
en fait tu vois c'est sur Youtube en
gros vous gagnez 1000 euros du million
de vues mais si vous gagnez de l'argent
c'est que vous le méritez sincèrement tu
as imaginé si on faisait ça à la télé
1000 euros du million de téléspectateurs
il y en a beaucoup qui seraient au Rémi
ça c'est
d'ailleurs Xavier vous en aviez marre
des journalistes qui vous déposent
toujours la question de combien vous
gagnez et je suis d'accord voilà du coup
vous gagnez combien sinon
Yvan Le boloc
le premier Giton voilà mélange de gitan
et de Breton crepo
hérisson chouchen 95 et du chouchen au
sans plomb et mais pas de Vannes sur les
Bretons moi j'ai un quart breton Thierry
et voilà c'était ma grand-mère
maternelle qui était alcoolique et en
tout cas pas d'amalgame sur les gitans
je vous jure les gitans c'est des gens
gentils si c'est des connards qui font à
bouffer dans une caravane c'est pas des
gitans c'est des bobos dans un food
truck rien à voir
ils vend le bolosse un peu notre Georges
Clooney français comédien beau gosse en
vieillissant s'est fait des couilles en
or avec le café
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser pierre gataz je vous dites qu'en
France le coup du travail est encore
trop cher à part naturaliser des Chinois
vous proposez quoi
mais c'est pas le c'est pas le salaire
net qui est embêtant ce sont les charges
que nous prenons sur le coup du travail
sinon moi je vais me proposition faites
comme Thierry payer au black
c'est la main noire
Natoo Natoo vous avez 31 ans ce qui fait
de vous l'une des doyennes de YouTube ça
fait quoi d'être la ligne Renault
d'Internet
faudrait vite que je me fasse un petit
lifting pour durer encore plus longtemps
et pour terminer ils vont le bologue ils
vont vous avez dit je veux être là où on
ne m'attend pas ça veut dire que le 6
mai prochain vous serez au côté de
Marine Le Pen
ah bah ça tu peux toujours te brosser
mon petit garçon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu